e
e e
good morning it's a little after 10:
a.m. sorry for the delay here I'm going
to go ahead and open the subcommittee
from the special Family Court committee
on title 4 and do we want to start with
the pledge
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank
you so I believe part of why we wanted
to to start this subcommittee was to
find
out how much money was coming in from
title 4 and then where it was going and
representative Smith actually found a
pretty comprehensive LBA report
which
shows the exact kind of amount in the of
the awards into the different areas so I
passed that copy around to everybody and
I'd like to see if if anybody had
anything that they wanted to add in
terms of things that they wanted to
discuss regarding
this yes representative
long yeah from what I we call the
testimony is
um that a lot of the child support
initiatives are to fund these
programs um so I'm wondering if
um I mean TANF I wouldn't think that
that' be one but some of these promoting
safe and stable families you know I'm
wondering if there's a tie in
from employees working on these programs
that there there's a lot of testimony uh
with they're looking for child support
because they get they get compensated
through the feds and they want want to
know uh like there's an incentive to
have John
support um so can you
hear oh
sorry so I did repl get some of that
information from attorney crean with the
court who was able to provide and I was
just trying to look and see how it maps
in where
come up come up even closer we don't B I
promise sit at one of these chairs here
and then we can all hear each other
because with any luck at all you have
information that could be helpful to us
that's why we
G
um yeah why don't we just I don't know
if if everybody knows who everybody is
if we want to just introduce each other
real quick I'm representative cab
representative representative
long representative
smithan thank you very
much what's the difference between the
two of you so he's doing tanif and she's
so she's doing title A tanif and she's
doing title 4 d which is child support
okay thank
you okay so
um attorney KGAN provided to us that in
under title
4D they get 1 million in
funding and their overall court system
budget is roughly 130 million so it's a
small it's less than 1% of their
operating budget and I was trying to see
if we can see here who was they you
should they get the court
court so I'm guessing that's what this
1.2 million is maybe we're rounding here
a little bit is
that well D is two lines
here um
is do you know like if the child 15 and
a half and then 1.2 well total yeah do
you know if the if the
14.3 billion is what goes to DHHS for
child support enforcement is that
approximately do you know approximately
if that's your operating budget for that
that I do
not okay
and she's um she's
party her yes okay and then she attorney
krian also mentioned that they also got
an additional 50k a year for the office
of mediation and arbitration which comes
from title 40 which is part of the axis
and visitation so that makes it like
1.05 so I'm sure that there's probably a
couple other programs that we just
didn't
do you mind turning your mic on thank
you so much just so everybody that's
watching could hear you have to pull it
closer uh if you look on the the back of
the the page it talks about what the uh
incentives are so it has to do with the
five key performance
areas and then depending on how you do
on those you get those incentive funds
which then have to be reinvested in the
program
so the performance areas of fraternity
support order establishment current
collections AAR Collections and cost
Effectiveness and how does New Hampshire
do on
those it I don't have the information in
front of me we always do very well in
paternity I know that um and then
we I we I don't think we're up to
getting 100% but we're somewhere between
70 and
100% but again I can I can get you that
information so I guess so do you know
exactly what kind of how the breakdown
of the incentive is I guess for for
establishing a support order and can you
explain what that means is that is that
in the is that in the sense of when the
court establishes the order or is that
in the sense of this person's in a rears
and we're finding that person and
establishing how the funds are going to
come through wage G establishment is
actually establishing an order Okay so
get when when they talk about patern
let's go through paternity establishment
obviously establishing paternity of of a
child who comes into one of our cases
that does not have a second parent on
the birth
certificate support order establishment
is establishing a support order for a
case and that can be the first temporary
order could be the final
Uso during the life during the life of a
case Uh current collection so
collections towards the the ter of art
is uh MSO which is the monthly support
obligation the current monthly support
obligation so that's what they they talk
about current
Collections and then aage collections
would be arear that had been owed prior
to the month that they're currently in
and then cost Effectiveness is a very
complicated math problem with regards to
how much is spent and then per how how
many dollars come in for child support
C could you tell
me
um what falls to the
department and what falls to the court
in terms of responsibility here is the
court making these determinations or is
the department making the determinations
determinations
well
um I'm looking at
establishing paternity establish modify
and enforce support obligations obtain
child and medical support for
children um you know all the those you
know do you make those determinations
and report them to the court for what is
your role and what is the Court's role I
guess is is would be my question does
that make sense yes yes it doesn't you
know just tell me it
doesn't um we are a a federally 66%
federally funded program so the federal
government has
said in order to get these funds you
need to do these various things which
includes all the stuff that's on here
and part of that that's allowed on in
the statutes and in the uh the Federal
Regulations is the use of um Cooperative
agreements with courts law enforcement I
think there's a couple others as well so
we have a Cooperative agreement or a
memorandum of understanding with the
court that describes our relationship
with regards to
what we do and what they do so then they
provide us with what we call expedited
process and then we pay them for the
time that they spend on cases so let me
ask you this is title 4D only is the
intention of that to recover
money for Tan families is that the
intent on that or is it for families
that are not
even it's both it started out originally
as tan of recovery but only less than
10% of our cases are tan of cases now t
t of cases are falling across the across
the
country and both cases both kinds of
cases get treated exactly the same so
we just bring them forward and then we
get an order we try to uh and then we
enforce it we also can take applications
from people who didn't who have a child
support order
already um and then they can bring it to
us to uh for
enforcement so if I may that so so child
support
incentives is just for your
division yes okay and theou you have
with the uh Family
Court does that payment come out of
this out of the incentives no comes out
of the regular the regular your your
regular buget as far as I know yes so is
there a line
item uh is there a line item that kind
of matches quasi matches what you paid
last year and what will be paid this
year now we're now we're getting into
areas that I don't know anything about
and that's your we can make people from
our finance division available to you to
ask to answer those type of questions
but okay and
66% um 66 66% of your division is
federally funded
correct through this alone Char sport
incentives no not the incentives the
incentives are separate oh so okay six
just the reg the regular budget and so
we have the regular budget and then we
have in incentives which are
extra so let me ask you this are the
only people that are involved in this
program people who didn't pay their
child support orders to begin with I'm
just trying to understand what what
establishes that the
person would go through title go through
your office rather than just paying the
other parent directly
what what is the you know the the
precursor to your office getting
involved is it well if we estab if we
helped to establish paternity then we're
going to stay involved in the case
indefinitely because we were involved
after that point or is it only if the
the party isn't
paying
we've the first
major differentiation between cases are
tan and on tan if you are on tanif
you've assigned your right to child
support to the state so you're required
to
cooperate so if there is a child if
there already is a child support order
we would just take it over and enforce
it if there isn't a child support order
which also includes if there isn't
paternity we would bring a case forward
establish paternity establish a child
support order and enforce
it when
the residential parent the the terms are
all over the place with regards to what
you call people but if the oblige or the
paye
then no longer wants our services they
can just say no longer want your
services we close our case and then they
can go forward and you know they have an
agreement how however however they they
get paid but the vast majority of our
cases are just an application from
somebody who wants their services which
most of the time is to paye in that they
want child support if they don't have an
order or they want their child support
enforced um if if they already have an
order we do get we do do take
applications from payors who want their
payments to go through us so that so
that there's a record so that they don't
have to worry
about proving they made
payments um we also help people with uh
modifications of child support the child
support order so those are the S those
are the sort of the broad broad brush s
to speak of how that works if I could
can you make those decisions
within the department or do you have to
get the court to agree we get a court
order because that's what our job is to
enforce the court orders so if the
parties
agree we can write up the agreement it's
called a uniform support order is the
requirement of of all child support
orders need to be on a uniform support
order so it makees sure we check all the
boxes so if the parties agree we get
them
together do do all the relev paperwork
and there's a lot of paperwork um and
then we can submit that to the court and
the court in most instances will sign
off on it then what's the fee for that I
guess the fee um if the only time we
charge a fee is if you've never been on
tanip then the paye is charged $35 a
year but if you've ever been on public
assistance there is no fee at
all and what is the time
schedule um schedule is not the right
word how long does it take from when
you prepare in order until the court
signs off on
it that's entirely impossible to predict
so much of it depends on the parties it
depends on which court we're dealing
with some courts are much more busy than
others um our stuff is generally handled
fairly quickly because we do have
expedited service from the
court um a lot of the times the biggest
issue is locating one or both of the
parties because we can't do anything
without we're looking for Dad we got to
be able to find Dad and we got to be
able to serve dad because we can't do
things in court without parties being
served so sometimes that can take a long
time and you say Dad um or mom well I
understand that but I mean do you say
Dad because it's more
likely to be
Dad where there might be
some delay
in locating him and not necessarily I
mean the
um it just it just depends on how easy
it is to locate them do they have an
actual uh a regular address are they
living where they've always lived or are
they couch surfing because the party's
just broke up and Dad
hasn't gotten an apartment yet so then
it's like where where is he how do we
serve him sometimes we can serve people
at at their jobs if they have a regular
address of their jobs things like that
it's a lot of people do the tanif or I'm
sorry do the application for services
because the the biggest tool that we
have in our toolbox is wage
assignment
so if you have a child support order we
get a wage assignment then then money
comes in the the rule is is that if when
an employer writes the employee a check
they're supposed to write write child
support a check so it should be coming
in it goes through our sdu which is our
uh secure our state dispersement unit
which brings the money in and then
writes a check right back out it's got
to be out within 48 hours it's usually
out within 24
hours that's important to note right and
then we keep all the records so
that years down the road they
um you verify right you can verify and
they don't have to go look for every
canceled check or argue that oh I gave
you cash or that type of thing and there
have been studies that talk about how uh
if if you take the money piece off the
table if Mom doesn't have to ask Dad for
a check or vice versa every time they
exchange the children or they give it to
the the child and the child you know
drops it in a puddle or whatever if the
if the money piece is sort of going
automatically that that it helps the
tensions between the parties sort of
relax because it's just one thing they
don't have to think
about now is the 66% funding that's
given is that given by a contract
between the the federal governing
program I guess and DHHS or how does
that work how does that 66% funding come
into
play that's a good question I mean we
are considered a for a a 4D agency it's
it's a function that the state of New
Hampshire is required to have and in the
like federally required fed required
right and in the broadest possible terms
because again this is all I this is the
way I think of it in my head because I
don't need to know anything more past
that um it's my understanding that we
take our
budget
monthly uh in some form and they and
send it to the feds and the FEDS send us
back 66% of that so basically this is
what we spent this month and then they
send us 66% back so we so we're required
essentially to engage with
the with the the federal program for for
child support enforcement that's like
that is a requirement
okay in terms of um your interaction
with the state judicial
branch
um if you were in
charge what would you do to make that
interaction better or is it just working
fine I would well we everybody always
wants more
people and I know that that the court is
working on that their budget has been
increased and that they're hiring people
and type things one of the things that
the court has um
that and and use in this process are
hearings officers so they're not judges
they deal with child support issues
only and I think they need a couple
more so we have we sort of have a mix of
where we get our orders in some some
Court we get them from the hearings
officers the hearings officers make
recommendations and the judges sign off
in some courts we we appear in front of
the judges so when you mean the differen
is in county by county at court by Court
yes court by Court okay there's 32
Family Division courts right now we we
have hearings in 30 of them because we
don't have hearing the uh C Brook
hearings are heard in Lancaster and
Candia hearings have been moved to Derek
is there a state plan I've heard
something referred to as a state plan
regarding child the child support
services and whatnot is is there a state
plan is and do you know where I can get
a copy of that oh I can get you a copy
so a state plan is part of the um the
federal statutes and regulations and it
it basically sort of lays out all the
pieces these are all the things you have
some of which um there are choices like
you can if if you want to do this you
can do it this way you can do it this
way just tell us which way you're doing
it okay so so when you say that we're
required I guess
to to do these things my my question is
is are we required in order to get the
funding or are we required just in
general that you have to you have to
have
these to do
okay I have a list of some of the
federal statutes which might be
helpful so with with respect to um the
court orders uh what percentage of those
would be wage
garnishments I don't have the number off
the top of my head but I would say more
than 70% More than
70% and do some people ask for that if I
if I'm a pay
and I'm voluntarily want to go through
you to keep the record straight can I
ask for that yes okay when do you know
when judges preside over these cases are
they reimbursed for each case that they
preside over no okay well it's
complicated there's theou and I'll have
I can get you a copy of the of theou the
judges judges time is not charged to the
expedited ser to the expedited uh
services that we get okay hearings
officers are and then there's a the
judge doesn't do peace work the judge
has a salary correct and I mean they
they they do but they've done they've
done time studies that that that show
what percentage of time do you spend on
4D information so the hearings officers
are not necessarily judges and they're
not paid as judges cor okay so are the
hearings officers attorneys or do you
know okay they're attorneys yes
um the hearing officer
does so I guess is there an incentive to
do are you paid separately for each one
of these five things in the sense of
like for each case if you establish you
know paternity um establish a support
order and then
you have you you have the person current
on Collections and all that are you
reimbursed that 66% for each of these
steps or is it just if we do these
things overall then we are reimbursed
for 66% of our overall operating budget
we only work on 40 40 cases so we get
66% of all of our expenses that have to
do with every case the incentives deal
with the entire case load it's not
individual cases it's percentage of
cases so paternity establishment we over
90% of our cases that needed paternity
establishment have paternity
establishment and is that what the
require is that what the the requirement
is more than 90% each one is is set
differently and I don't I don't have
that the state plan yes okay Y and then
the same thing with how many of your
cases have orders established how many
of your cases have a payment this
month towards current support how many
cases have payments towards rear and
then cost Effectiveness is a whole
different set of math okay um and then
I'm going to ask a question that some I
guess it got asked of the Court as well
are the employees that are handling
this or these cases are they paid on
like a salary basis or are there any
incentives for them like bonuses or
whatnot for more of these types of C we
are state employees we get paid just
like every other state employee I
thought so but I wanted to just sorry to
ask the question but I wanted to get it
on the record that that's not how that
works I and I understand that the turn
incentive can be a little
confusing so with respect to uh Child
Support Enforcement are the feds
qualifying that well yes because because
they they're dealing with
the collections of current support and
then collections of the aers so that's
that's the enforcement side okay but
like the goal is to achieve positive
outcome for children by addressing the
needs and responsibility of the parents
right do they do they look at what
you've done or or do you just
put that category down in
$80,000 and they'll give you 66% no they
look they definitely we are audited
yearly so they verify oh yes oh yes most
of the things in the
Uso the
Uso's I think seven pages long now five
of which get filled out two of which are
instructions um most of the requirements
that are on that are things that the FED
that that the feds have required over
over time with regards to what's
supposed to be on there notices to the
parties about things that happen um
medical supports a big thing takes up
like a page at one point years ago and
I've been with the department for 24
years so feels like a million some days
um at one point they were moving medical
support into they were that was going to
be another one of these incentive
categories but um it's been bogged down
uh with the feds so are there any
federal employees that are part of bccs
or is it all New Hampshire state
employees it's all New Hampshire state
employees and we have contracts with
various vendors that perform certain
things but if you're talking about
enforcement of Child
Support it's state employees we are
we're based in we have 11 district
offices one in each County and two in
two in Hillsboro one in Manchester one
in
ASA and that's where the cases are are
based out of the district offices
because they're they're the ones who
start the cases on the enforcement end
or the establishment end and then
they're the ones who live with the cases
on the enforce enforcement end and is
not a federally assigned employee
overseeing aspects of this through
aspects of the state's incentives no
okay so there no I mean we have we have
a a federal office out of Boston that
that uh overseeing is is a is too strong
a word that you know they they offer
support mostly a lot of technical type
type things um my understanding that the
ones we have right now they're they're
having issues with Staffing as well but
they don't uh they're not even attorneys
so and they covered New England and
Boston yes region one is uh New England
all right so is bcss is it a federally
contracted program or is it just that
it's federally required but it's not
contracted I'm just right it's not
contracted not contracted okay have you
has there ever been a t I hope if you
don't want to answer any of these
questions of course you don't have to
and if we are really you know digging
down there and you want to say enough we
understand don't please you
know has there ever been a time when the
state has
not passed
muster in the
annual review by the
feds that's that's a hard question to
answer
um there are different different levels
of passing and it depends on on which
review there's a lot of
reviews and they do a data
reliability review which is
their that's yearly um because obviously
they they they check our system to make
sure that the system which is
Nexus
um shows the same information that's
actually in the file because the data
which we deal with that's all in in the
database needs to be accurate
so that's that's their sort of biggest
thing we also deal with the IRS we've
got uh they review us I believe it's
every three
years you you mentioned that the there's
a bcss federal office that's in Boston
so let's say that somebody in New
Hampshire has a complaint can they
complain to the New Hampshire Federal
office like is that I mean the sry
Boston federal office okay and then how
does that work like then they they would
get
most likely get in touch with our
director and they'd figure figure it out
from there and that's the closest
Enforcement office well we enforcement
is done throughout all our I meant
federally federally yes yeah okay yes
they they don't turn it over to you to
enforce they enforce it themselves so if
I called and complained about something
they would give me a resolve they
wouldn't say turn it over to you and
tell me call whever it really depends on
the case I mean they're gonna they're
gonna have to check in with us because
they don't know anything about the case
right and they wouldn't have any access
to it right how it then gets handled
it's really going to depend on what the
what the but are there times when they
would I would be in stay in contact with
the regional office yes I mean they okay
but sometimes they'll just the regional
office will just turn it over to you yes
and is it is it to you or to the
director as a specific person who would
they reach out it would be the director
first who's and who is the director
latowski okay
and then she would bring in whichever uh
you know she'd make a team of of who she
would think appropriate based on what
the the nature of the complaint is
okay
yes I have a really basic question and I
apologize um but I want to go all the
way back to the beginning just to make
sure I really have a clear understanding
and anybody who's watching has a clear
understanding too um so it's my
understanding from what you're saying is
that only those who receive the can if
are required to participate in a wage
garnishment program the well they're
required to to participate in the child
support program okay the wage assignment
is a piece of that but it's not all of
it and if they did not receive that do
the person who's the obligator whoever's
paying um do they acknowledge or sign
anything anywhere to know that this is a
voluntary um that they are not required
to participate that they can make
personal payments and do they
acknowledge that through putting their
signature on a piece of paper saying
that they're voluntarily um enrolling in
this there's an application process it's
all application driven if we don't have
an application we can't enforce that
order okay and both have to apply no
just one so if one applies and then so
if the one person who's receiving the
money applies and the other person who's
paying the money says I don't want to do
that then what happens then the case is
still open with us and we enforce it and
technically they can they can go to
court to to ask them to ask the court to
have us not be the enforcer of the case
but if the if the order says that it's
payable through us it's payable through
us they would have to get the order
changed to have it be payable to
directly to the oblig so they'd have to
go so just again for clarification so
one parent puts in an application that
they want to get paid directly that way
and not through a personal check um and
then what's the next step does it go
back to the courts or does the person
who's paying now have to pay for an
attorney to go back to court to say I
just want to pay on my own I don't want
you know I'm perfectly capable of paying
my own I don't want to participate I I'm
not understanding how does it then get
decided that one person gets to say what
they want to do and the other person has
no inut that's what the this this the
statute says as long as the let's let's
take an example every application is
approved was what you're saying well the
application is they're always approved I
mean assuming they've given us the
information that we need there is no
there is no qualification like tan up
where you have to have a certain type
thing so I guess that's where I'm it's
it's voluntary but it's voluntary on I
understand because you've got the two
the two people okay so that's what I'm
getting at so it's really not voluntary
it's one person saying what they want
and the other one has to go along with
it without any saying process there are
circumstances under which it doesn't
have to be it it can't it
so what is the process if the other
person doesn't want to
participate um in having let's take an
example non tanip yeah no Take that off
they get divorced right they get
divorced they have a uniform support
order
okay on the second page it's there's a
check off box for payable to it's either
to the oblig or bcss and then it says
other if it's payable to bcss which is
what we usually advise the courts to
do and the oblige applies for services
we will take the ca we we take the
case forward because it's payable
through us and we have an application
and then is that only the $35 a year or
do you take a percentage of those funds
$35 a year so you guys don't get any
percentage of the nope
okay so we so we're still going back to
what I said the other person are they
being made aware that they can they
challenge it or can they set up a
different account to deposit directly
into the child's that gets done during
the child support hearing or the divorce
hearing or
whoever okay and is someone there to
guide um the other one to let them know
what their options are that I'm not in
the room so I I I it depends
on what kind of hearing or meeting
they're having where the Uso gets put
together okay uh the court has case
managers the court has mediation the
court has court hearings so and at any
one of those points a Uso can be issued
if the parties agree okay so if the
parties agree that that that dad's GNA
pay mom and is gonna do a um direct
deposit or if they've never had any
concerns with regards to yes he's going
to pay me you know we get a long fine we
just don't want to be married anymore
you can do that
and then it's payable to the oore we
never payable to the oig we never see
the case they go on their merry way but
then what what'll happen is that if when
if if Dad stops
paying mom can come to us and say I need
help in forcing it and there are there's
part of the statute that that talks
about what the rules are um mostly she
would need to come in and say he's 30
days behind on child support if he's 30
days behind on child support we file
something with this called and notice to
make payable
which basically says Dear oore since
you're 30 days behind we're taking over
enforcement and they don't like that
they can ask the court for year right I
understand that and I I appreciate that
part of it that when that happens I
guess from the people who came in who to
testified before us I think the question
was that they or the concern was that
they weren't aware that they even had an
option of saying I prefer not to do that
and I prefer to um pay directly um and I
think that was where there was kind of a
contention there um and I think I guess
that's what I'm trying to get out is how
do we make sure before they sign a paper
that they know that they have that there
are specific options for them if they
don't have an attorney there to explain
it to them I mean there are instructions
on the on the uniform support order that
there's a check off box where you can
say the parties agree to make this
payable you know between themselves to
have no wage assignment because
then they explain it so it's the option
is right there on the form again I'm
been in a full divorce hearing since I
was in private practice so okay I guess
I'm going to come from the other aspect
when I hear somebody say well the
options are on the form and the people
can read it unfortunately we know that
so many people are not reading um or
would even understand this and so I
think that's where I get concerned
because I think that things have to be
verbally explained to people they have
to accept understand acknowledge that
they actually understand it and I think
that when people are in these really
contentious or even just this very high
anxiety kind of a time they're going to
sign things without really understanding
what they're signing then they come in
and they testify and say I didn't even
know and then you get that thrown back
well you should have read it and it's
like but we know that half our society
is not reading at proficient levels um
so I I guess that's where I'm coming
from is to making sure that before
people sign it that everything is
explained that they know their options
um
and and we make sure that we're not
coming back to the table because they're
they didn't understand what they were
I'm unclear as to how much information
the Court gives people I know that
they're required to watch some videos at
a first appearance when they first start
this whether they deal with that or not
and then again with the case managers
and with the
mediators about how much they actually
explain right okay that might be an area
done for the part we to look in that
more information is always better than
less information you mentioned that the
application is is done by Statute and I
was pulling that up that's 458a is that
what that's
under and if so I'm I'm my question
regarding that is is that is it required
by federal law or or the federal program
that we have these statutes in place in
order to be able to receive that 66%
funding or just in general is it
required that we
have sort of both they there are are
definitely requirements which is part of
the state plan of you shall have these
things and who writes the state
plan the the requirements of the state
plan are set out in federal statute and
regulations the requirements are fedal
each state shall have a state plan and
each state plan shall
have these many things some of which
are you shall have a wage assignment
statute you shall have a driver's
license replication uh system that type
of thing a lot of it has to do with the
the Nexus in the computer system as well
and so who actually does that work is
there is it a is it multiple people or
is it the director that mostly takes
care of that well putting together the
state plan yeah well the state plan is
is sort of housed in our policy
department and they're they're the ones
who sort of keep it together as a as
a document and then anytime we make a
change to the document including our the
new guidelines worksheet we're going to
have to change the state plan um anytime
we change it we have to give it to the
feds and the feds have to approve it
does that go to jail car at all
no it's so it the approval process
involves the feds but not
State corre okay thank you yes we do
have a couple we do have a couple of
internal of um regulations that and
rules that we go through through ja
power but not those not the state
plan if you look at it's the the federal
statute that deals with with all of this
is 42 USC 651 through 669 can you say
that one more time sorry 42
USC 651 through
669 thank you and one of those
specifically deals with the state plan
does the does the administrative office
of the Court have have weigh in with the
state plan as well or is it just d H HS
it's just the HHS okay and are there
requirements in the state plan for the
court I would I'm just curious because I
guess I would see now that you're
mentioning the the
worksheet it would be then a requirement
of the court to use that worksheet right
right well the worksheet is required by
Statute okay so
okay by federal statute or state statute
state statute
so to go back to your previous question
458 a that's that's the uniform child
custody jurisdiction and enforcement
action that doesn't Adit yeah no sorry I
think I gave the wrong one we start 458b
which is the income assignment 458 C
which is child support
guidelines so B and C yeah and then we
skip to
461a 14
which is where all the child
support stuff
is
okay and then if you want to have a lot
of
fun you can read
youa which is four or sorry
546b that's the uniform Interstate
Family Support
act which deals with cases between
states and between countries okay um and
I know that we have a quadrennial child
support report that comes out which is
statutorily required I
believe does that report and I I've read
through much of it but it's a huge
report I know that it had suggested you
know changes to the way that we do some
you know the child support calculations
and stuff
which we made a few changes on that this
year and we'll see what happens the next
time but are there other changes in
there that are relative to rec
recommendations for updating of the
state plan and the ways that we do
things that are not legislative or is
that mostly just suggestions
on the legislative piece of it I guess
it's most it has to do with the
guidelines so if it's not sort of
guidelines
specific it it that's that's all it went
to because that's the only thing that's
supposed to just guidelines yeah just
guidelines and do you know if we've ever
actually I'm curious
um CH you know
changed per those
recommendations we've done some
um it's been difficult I
mean we've
had we don't take a position with
regards to what the guidelines should be
we do the review we present the
review to the people in this building
and then it's up to them to to decide if
they think our if our guidelines are
fair and appropriate or whatever the
language is in the in the in the statute
to to keep
going as long as they're 4D compliant
meaning
that it meets all the the the
requirements for from the 4D
program and those requirements are the
ones that are in the US the 4D T USC 651
through
669 um and then somebody mentioned some
sort of like a Cooperative agency
agreement with the
DMV we have a cont we have anou with
with with the with the DMV for our
license
verification now I'm curious on a piece
of that have has there do to your
knowledge has there ever been any
challenge with I guess the
constitutional right to travel and the
the license being hold to your knowledge
has
that I can look I mean I'm sure it's
been challenged has it been challenged
successfully I don't believe so and
that's a federal requirement right it is
a federal requirement that that's 161
b11 and nothing about the logic of
saying that a person
who might need that license in order to
be able to get to a
job who would no longer be able to get
to the job to earn the money that's
needed to pay the child's
support I guess what I would say is we
wouldn't take the license of somebody
who had a
job so generally generally the the issue
is they come in well how am I supposed
to get a job if I don't have a driver's
license and the thing is is you've got a
driver's license now and you're not
making their payments if somebody has a
job and they're making they're making
their payments there's no reason we
would take their take their D's license
thank you that's except for we we are
allowed we don't we haven't I don't
think we've ever actually done it at
least in my my tenure um if somebody's
refusing to cooperate with paternity
testing technically we can take their
license well but we usually don't we
usually don't do that we usually just
take them to court and have the judge
yell at them and then then they'll show
up um and is
that so that's the department is
actually authorized to revoke the
license and it doesn't necessarily have
to go through court so you don't there's
not really due process on that I guess
the due process is built into the
statute they have notice we don't it's
it's not a question of they
uh suddenly get pulled over because they
don't have a license they get a they get
they get a notice there's time type
built into the built into the uh into
the statute and then a lot of times it's
a way to get somebody's attention
they're not paying they're not
contacting us they're not letting us
know what let us know what's happening
and then we we say if you don't do this
we're going to take your license then
they get a hold of us and go well I
broke my leg six weeks ago and it's like
dude you didn't tell us you know we need
to we need to know what's happening
especially in cases we can help them get
a modification if they're not working
and have a good reason not to be working
we can help them get a modification of
their
order but we can't do that if they don't
talk to
us I believe we have yes and it's not uh
just driver's
license but if they're working and
making their payments we wouldn't take
it like you can can have a CDL but if
you're not using
it and we we also do come in with
negotiations so if somebody came to us
and said look I can get this job but I
need my license we will contact the
employer to to confirm that that's
what's happening and we will give the
license
back they right they don't I don't if if
they verif I don't know what it how
exactly what what they would what that
would look
like we are also U it's not just
driver's licenses we can do professional
uh licenses we get a a very good turnout
for um hunting
licenses some people don't care about
their driver's license but Bo they care
about what's
their agreement with fishing game for
that yes what's the reinstatement
process that I'm not um I might be
skipping over it but so let's say you've
revoked somebody's driver's license how
do they get it back let's say hey they
they now have this great job offer but
they need to be able to drive to work
how how would they go about getting we
we send a notice to DMB asking them to
revoke the revocation or resend the
revocation so is there is that is there
like um jail car rules on that because
I'm just not seeing no I don't believe
there are it's it's just you guys just
do it like it's in
how or is it just there we go if you
look um sorry 161
B1 Roman Neal
six when an obligor after certification
subse subsequently complies with the
legal order of support the department
shall provide the obligor with a written
release indicating the obligor is comp
with the legal order of support but but
they're not going to be in compliance at
this point because they need the job in
order to get back the the aers that they
owe but that means they're I mean we're
gonna we're g to put it together for
them so that they're going to get a good
job with especially a wage assignable
job I mean that's that's the point is to
get them is to get them working we don't
take their license because well do you
think that that piece of the statute
should be updated because it says when
they subsequently comply with the order
the department shall give them a written
release but what about before they
comply but they're making a good faith
attempt to comply by getting that job
like is there any is there any is there
ever anyone who is denied
we would want something from the
employer to show that
it's
right not no because I mean in theory
there there could be
legitimate jobs that don't have wage
assignment a available but that's going
to be a harder
row
too right and a lot of times the other
thing they'll do is they'll be like all
right you know you need you have a job
you need to show me that you can that
you're making your payments so even if
you don't have a a you know a real job
they're doing Uber and door Dash and all
those other things but if they start
making their payments they'll they'll
come to an agreement with them of of
what they think's going to work and it's
like okay if you show me you know three
weeks in a row you're you're making your
payments then we'll have a discussion
now do you think that that should
potentially be updated though because it
doesn't really
require that the license be given back
until they have complied with the order
I guess it's just that's a little bit
concerning to me because especially I I
hear what you're saying about well for
sure if the job has wage garnishment
then we're going to do that
but if the job doesn't because maybe
they're getting a job at a small
landscaping business that just doesn't
doesn't have enough employees where wage
garnish because I think that's the
requirement for wage garnishment right
like there has to in order for wage
garnishment to be applicable it has to
be a certain number of employees or
something how does that work if it's a
if it's a W2 job the employers are
required
to go with it okay so it's when it's if
you're getting a contract position like
w49
10 there's legal debate over that as
well given given the definition of
income but right now we we don't ask for
wage assignment against 1099 wages okay
so I mean I guess do you think that like
legislative we should provide a way
saying if the
person
is you know
is is trying to become imp if the person
needs their driver's license in order
to go to the job which they have a job
offer for because we'd want to make sure
we said that they actually had the job
offer not not just that they need the
license in order for employment because
then like you're saying sometimes they
don't try and actually get a job but
let's say that they do have a job offer
from for employment that there's a
path for them to be able to get the
license back because I'm only seeing in
the statute it's saying that they shall
provide it when they comply with the
order could because could anybody just
decide hey I'm not I'm I'm just not
going to give you your license back
because I just don't really believe
you're going to pay
it we usually put together an agreement
that says
is that's just with the relationship
between the case worker and the and the
oore and there's no rules on that it's
just how that person right every every
case is different and there's no role or
let me reward that is do you see a role
for either the legislature or jail car
in that process I don't know anything
about jail car um are you
lucky that's what I've heard
um so how that how that would get
involved I that I don't but but
you
your work relationships with the
relative departments fishing game DMV
whatever and with um the two
parties um whichever terms you want to
use for them the pay the pay or the you
know o or
whatever those
proceed in a as smooth and timely a way
as they
can without you seeing the need for
legislative intervention is that
true I mean I'm not saying that
legislative intervention is
never needed but I guess I just don't
know what it would look like in this in
this
circumstance
um just because there are so many
different scenario scenarios about how
this
happens can you turn on your mic sorry
yeah if if we would if we would change I
think a case where work with with an
individual has a better Rapport than if
we statutorily
said if somebody comes to you uh with a
job offer and they need a
license um then you may you must uh I I
it doesn't seem like it because what I
heard in testimony is
that as soon as they get a hold of the
person that's in a rage and talk about
their license I'm looking at a 90% of
the time or that somebody uh would get
back to you if you're looking to take my
license I'm I'm giving you a call and
I'm cutting a deal that I those type of
numbers I don't have have in front of me
but it is it is one of our most useful
tools right okay so I mean I guess
though but is there a way to appeal it
what if you have
a what if you have a a case worker who
just they don't like this person and
they don't want
an internal um administrative appeal
unit you do yes in
DHHS okay um and then I know you said
that there's like the $35 a year fee but
I'm curious of the weight of the money
that's I guess garnished from the wages
or whatever that's that's taken that for
somebody that's not on tanip how much of
that actually goes to the oblige all it
except except for the $35 so they get
100% of it so you you you take in $1,000
you give the other parent $1,000 okay
the only time that would be different is
if there are tan aers because somebody
can be on tanip and then be come off
tanip and there might still be a reers
owed to
tanif um the fed the all the money the
rule is all the money goes to the
oblige first and then to tan except for
federal tax
refunds that we take from
I IRS those are required by federal
statute to be paid towards Tanana perers
first if there're No Tan of perers then
they would go to so the an employee an
employer um they get compensated for uh
doing that added work for um I I think
they're allowed
to to charge like a dollar
it's
458b 458
B6 in addition to the amount withheld
for support in a reage the employer May
deduct a fee of $1 for each withholding
so it's
$1 that's they can I don't think they
have to and I'm okay and where does that
dollar come from it doesn't come from
the it would come out correct correct it
would come from the
avore okay so they would take $300 from
his check send us a check for
$299 okay and keep $1 do you know if
there's somewhere we could find out like
how
many cases that there are per year and I
guess what case type that they
[Music]
are I mean we have we have those
breakdown breakdown of numbers our case
load right now is about 28,000 oh you do
have could you send those to us of
course so you're just looking for Tan up
versus non- tanip or anything else just
title four cases in general like how
many there are and you know the
breakdown of I guess kind of what they
are
okay it's always it's always more
Enforcement cases than establishment
cases because obviously establishment
cases turn into enfor
and then Enforcement cases live as long
as the cases are open which can be years
and years and years is there also a way
to track um
Interstate cases where the party has
moved from or no longer is in the
Hampshire yes we have a an entire
separate Interstate
unit that deals with where the C the
court case is being done in a different
state so they're charge so basically
whoever had applied for services usually
the oblige is here in New Hampshire but
New Hampshire for some reason doesn't
have jurisdiction over the obligor so
then we send the case to the appropriate
State and ask the state there to
establish if we don't already have an
order and then to
enforce and it is that a process that
generally Works smoothly do you need
individual um mlus with other states or
is it just standard the UA the
458b uniform Interstate Family Support
Act is a required piece of legislation
that's required the the feds required
all 50 states to pass it exactly the
same okay thank you you had to ask for
permission to change a
word so in theory it should go it's to
me it's still amazing after all this
time that each state still does stuff
different um based on how their state
set up um I mean I could complain about
Florida forever but that's a whole other
thing does this does the state plan
contain all the details on all Theus
that you guys have
or good
question it may or it may not but I can
get you all of the all of the use that
we that we yeah that would be great just
so we have all the we have all the
information that would be if that's an
easy thing for you to get so I have to
go back I want I want to go back to ask
the chair a
question are
we this has been incredibly helpful I
can't thank you enough for your being
willing to be here and to answer all
these questions and I think those of us
on the committee
um really appreciate
it but I want to go back one step
because
my understanding which might be
completely off base is that what brought
us to this isn't how
DHHS handles this but how the court
handles it and are there problems that
the family court the problems with how
the family
court handles and so
far what I've taken from this morning's
discussion is that the
responsibility rests very
solidly in the
department and that the family
court is just uh just puts it in
premature on
what the department has worked out and
it would appear that they are doing that
in as timely a manner
as is
reasonable is is that an accurate
assessment I would I would agree with
that I mean we we use the Federal the
Family Division
system because obviously there are the
Family Division has cases that don't
have anything to do with DHHS right um
we we're given block scheduling um
expedited expedited service so we can
generally get in a little faster maybe
um but they don't do anything to our
cases that they wouldn't do with anybody
else the forms are the same standards
are the same um it's just that we're
we're bringing it
I think we'd have to go back and talk I
want to have a little talk with chairman
Pearson about this because I think part
of it was this came over from the
other committee as well where they had
been discussing it through the
the through it was through um the work
that what do you call that committee the
um special Department of Child the the
the one that the DHHS that Eric go L on
is
chering oh that's the D the dcyf one I
think part of that came I think part of
that was yeah because it came up as like
it came up in there but it wasn't really
necessarily appropriate in that so it
right so it came back over to here
although I think Ito either yeah because
I think it's more of like a DHHS so I
but I want to it would be nice if you
don't if it's easy to send the data just
so we have the data can give them the
data and then I want to see what we if
anything should be done with it because
I do agree that it does seem what where
it does seem some things
maybe there could be some legislative
recommendations they're not really
falling on the court part of it they're
more
on the administrative part of it and and
as we discussed I'm not sure how much we
want to legis legislative mandate things
ver letting the case workers work
through them but I do
think it would be nice if there were
some I
mean I I hear where you're trying to go
Madam chair and and I'm quite
sympathetic but it seems to me what we
could
say was that this conversation has been
very helpful very informative we've
gotten a good deal of of data and the
bottom line is this um while no system
is perfect and there always is room for
improvement none of this has anything to
do with the family
court
unless unless the division's enforcement
they have to go to like if they pull my
license I may I may file with the court
to can I don't see that you can do that
under the stat
stue yeah it's an administrative process
I mean people do try to get the court to
get them back but the court explains
part of me wonders if there should be a
way through the court to be able to
appeal that but I mean I again I don't
know that that's actually and I I guess
I think in some of the things we've
heard people have felt that the court
should have given it back but I don't
see that
they are legisl that that's
legislatively permissible for them to do
that it seems like it does go through
the depart
so maybe they got blame you know kind of
I don't want to say blame but blame for
lack of a better word for something that
they had no control over they don't they
don't have the power to do that and I
wonder if should they have the power to
do that I don't know but I don't see
things that they actually have the power
to do right now that's under the family
court that seem problematic it's more
things that are not within their perview
I guess is the better way for me to say
it and this has been extremely helpful
and I really do appreciate you coming
and I don't I I don't know if um Brian
if you had anything that you wanted to
add because I I really appreciate you
coming as
well uh no thank you okay I thank you so
much for all of this information it's
been great it's been really extremely
helpful did anybody else have any other
questions
for do you have an email address do you
want me to send all that to is there a
general special committee or should I
send it to if you could send it to me I
can forward it out to the to the
committee so the whole committee has it
yeah if I if I could just uh one one
other question on
tanif uh it's it's the higher it's the
higher number and we're hearing that
tanif has been going
down I think she said it was about 10%
right well I mean year to date it's 28
million 28 and a half million oh I meant
of the cases were 10% is that what
you're asking right
right how was that
number how was that number figured in
the
66% it is
there the the 66% is that broken down
into the uh ABD
and no it's not no all right so it's
just here is 66% in the state of the
child support program right
and but costs for the child support
program are subid
6% okay so TANF is um
that's right uh what is that 34%
so so you add 34% and that's the actual
TANF
appropriation
right to the
child their own no
right
okay just one more clarification for me
um the revoking of licenses is the thing
that really makes my ears perk up and so
I just wanted to other than the driver's
license you mentioned professional or
fishing game is taking the professional
or fishing game I know you said the
driver's license is the federal says
that you can do that moving over and
taking per professional licenses or fish
and gain licenses is that required under
federal or is that something we're just
doing as a state as a means having
something in our toolbox in addition to
taking a driver's license I will have to
double check on that for you but I'm
pretty sure it's just licenses doesn't
it doesn't
specify okay I and the reason I'm asking
that is because I do I get concerned
with the fishing game one because there
are people who hunt purely to get food
and um so when we have so much food
insecurity I'm like well wait a minute
now we're we're interfering with their
ability to get the food to put in their
feet um their freezer um so that's in it
it just I don't know something just
didn't sit right with me but I'd like to
know if that's required by the federal
government or if that's something we're
just doing as a state thank
you guess oh well my understanding is
that these numbers are low uh can we can
we get numbers of those that actually
had license pulled or those that
actually
had uh you know their fishing game
license their hunting license or
whatever we have
okay database with regards to yes they
the license but which license okay so it
seems like I want to make sure I
understand it correctly it seems like
the areas where the court actually is
involved with title four is merely to
establish the support order through the
worksheet um and then do they do the
court order for establishing
paternity yes it's all I mean it's all
one piece you you you come in you ask
for paternity and child
support in general we'll do the
maternity piece first hopefully
everybody
cooperates then we move on to j court
and that's through the court
though well it depends I mean if we have
a child for daughter and dad has a job
at you know Boeing we put in a wage
assignment we get money from thing yay
everybody's good some I mean a lot of
cases you never go back you don't have
to you know money's coming in money's
going out you review it every three
years um for
appropriateness and everything's off I
mean to bring it back to court that
something we would have to ask for or
the parties can ask as well it's their
case so um so the court is only involved
with the establishment of support order
sometimes paternity establishment and
then if they want to go back for the was
it every three or four every four years
modification every three years or
anytime either of the parties um have a
substantial change in
circumstance and is the modification
every three years one of the parties has
to ask for that right so those are
really the only times that the court
itself is getting involved with DHHS
right except for well for the title cor
show what now what's that so at the end
of the enforcement process we try to we
use a lot of
different administrative processes
driver's license credit bureau leans
against Real Property that type of thing
um but if somebody's not paying we can
take them to court for what called show
cause which is basically them having to
explain to the
court those are handled by our child
offic
so the so the the show cause hearings
don't go to court they do go to court
theyed
okay so if I had my license pulled and
I'm still not paying that would be a
show that that you would motion to court
I'd have to explain right why
okay all right so just really those
three areas that the court is involved
with and besides that it's mostly just
done
through DHHS itself without Court
involvement
ad this is not the other piece that's
not handled by
the uh Family Division that actually the
Superior Court we do have a criminal non
support
unit because the failure to pay child
support is when it gets to a certain
level it's also a
crime and that's and that can you say
the name the name of that again criminal
non support criminal nons support
right and that's through Superior Court
right so what we do in those cases is we
put together a packet we send it to the
appropriate County
attorney and if they want to bring the
case forward we help them prep the case
we testify and then we through our
statute we have the ability to act
as pration parole officers if somebody
is convicted but doesn't get jail but we
do have people who have get jail
how often does that situation occur very
rarely very rarely I me you really have
to the issue is in child boort is always
ability to pay and that I mean that's at
the The Establishment level the
enforcement level and then when you get
to per and then you have to prove it
beyond the reason and is very rare does
that mean
like one to five cases a year less than
10 like less definitely less than 10 um
some of that has to do with we don't
have the resources to bring to bring the
case forward um but it's also it's it's
something we want to do really it's not
we're not if we have a case where we
know the out has a drug problem and you
know doesn't really have a place to live
and hasn't had a real job that they've
kept for more than a month in four years
we're not going to put them in
j u the point you know we're trying to
get we're trying to collect the child
support and having somebody
like that then all they do is they come
out of jail and now they're
Fel and less likely and less but there
are people and we have gotten um you
know people who
are not going to pay they have the
ability to pay they're
not and those can be pretty satisfying
so if the parties don't agree for
establishing paternity that's when you
would go into court for the
establishment corre and then the court
could order that they have to do right
then they have to show
up and then we R do the
testing
and tell everybody once the testing's
done assuming that they are dead then we
ask the court to schedule Med on the
issue of child support and when we do a
child support order we will check off
the Box on the Uso
that makes him the dad so that they'll
change person okay
all right so I guess like as a committee
I would just thank you so much it's been
hugely helpful I guess as a committee I
would say that I just kind of summarized
that you know the majority of all
administration of title for is through
DHHS in the only areas that the court
administers Are Family Court by
establishing the uniform support order
and paternity establishment if the party
refuses testing the modification every 3
years if a party requests it or sooner
if a party request it because of a
significant change and then show cause
hearings and then criminal non support
support
orders um are through Superior Court and
that's very rare you know less than 10
cases a year so those are really the
only pieces So within those pieces does
anybody here feel that there's a need
for any
recommendations through those Family
Court pieces
so enforcement isn't one of those uh the
Court's not
involved well other other than what she
had mentioned uh because I believe some
of the enforcement is what you had
mentioned but I I just wanted to make
sure that there's no other enforcement
that the court would be involved other
than what she already
stated that so that would be
okay does anybody on the commit feel
that regarding the family court piece of
it that we should consider
any I that we should consider any
recommendations on the Family Court only
pieces that we've discussed do you think
that there should changes that should be
considered on any of these Family Court
pieces or do you guys feel like this any
of the changes that you're thinking
might necessarily be more DHHS base
changes and they're not they're outside
of the purview of the family
court I don't see any I don't see
any my conclusions and they're only my
conclusions they're not the conclusions
of the
committee after the year or more that
we've spent on this is that there are
problems with the family court and to me
the
problems come down again and again
to the lack
of
essential
Staffing support to the judges
clerks
um other organizational and
administrative difficulties that make
it almost impossible for the judges to
carry out the resp responsibilities that
we expect them to carry out and that is
where I see the problems rather
than um in other
areas and with respect to uh male
female
punishment
um I yeah I don't
see I mean with the new guidelines that
became effective uh July
first September they the new guidelines
become effective January 1st January 1st
of
25 okay um yeah I I think those guidel I
think the new guidelines will help that
matter it's just a matter
of I'm just trying to think of the um
you know the complaints testimony that
we get
um and the new guidelines I think will
suppress some of that testimony that I
he negative testimony to towards the
court so yeah I don't I don't
see I don't see what else we can do with
the courts I don't find
that all did you have me I would like to
reserve my opinion on that because um
we've heard a lot of great information
today but we've also requested um some
information and I think until I have an
opportunity to really look at that and
digest it um I'd like to reserve uh my
opinion at this point that's
reasonable okay I was just looking back
on like the original I guess kind of
charge of us as a subcommittee which was
to research title four of the Social
Security Act specific to the state of
New Hampshire how much is collected hi
how why and where does it go and I think
we
have with this information like
the a rough outline of of that
information and then we'll
get further information out of this
state plan so I think
we've done the research that was
suggested out of this and let's let's
take the time to I guess go through see
if
anybody finds anything in that that they
want to bring up and
I know that chairman Pearson was
suggesting doing a final
meeting of the overall
subcommittee I I think he suggested we
do that on October 22nd so he was
looking to hear back from us before the
full committee so do we want to meet one
more time before then
to see if there's anything else that we
wanted
to what what are your
thoughts how long do you think it will
take to get I'm not sure how readily
available some of this stuff is how long
do you think it would take approximately
to a week okay
um so do we want to play and maybe to
meet October
8th would 10: a.m. work for everybody
all right I think that kind of concludes
for us today unless anybody else has
anything thank you all so much I really
appreciate
it e